along with it uh guys check this shot
out as we're looking for black mountain
across the valley
this is the big screen on resorts world
you can
see it from black mountain that's how
amazingly huge it is
look how small the plane looks so much
smaller than that big digital screen on
resorts world down the strip
it looks a little hazy this morning we
missed out on the rain for monday so
we're going to have to be happy
with that 100 of an inch on sunday now
we know that some south and
southeast valley neighborhoods and
southwest got a little bit more than
that over a tenth of an inch so that's
great
but officially we're still sitting at
less than half of where we need to be
for this time of year and we're going
into our hot dry season
here for a month or two until monsoon
season starts up
in july right now we've got 60s and 70s
and we'll look for a lot of sunshine and
a lot more heat today getting back into
those hotter mid 90s this afternoon so
that's pool weather
65 and searchlight 71 in boulder city
mid 60's in mesquite indian springs and
prompt down around 60 degrees
cali any at 44. we're going to wait for
the winds and boy are they coming back
with a vengeance
breezy tonight but downright gusty into
wednesday and thursday
fire weather watches have already been
issued behind the winds though come a
big drop in temperatures
mid 70s by friday wow all right so
yesterday
we had thunderstorms up in lincoln
county a little rain through the spring
mountains
that's really it this low pressure
system is already whirling its way
over into the planes and the rockies all
these areas of orange these are fire
weather watches
that start tomorrow at noon and go all
the way until almost midnight thursday
for us with dry
windy conditions those winds tomorrow 35
plus miles an hour continuing into
thursday
winds should be light today that uv
index is 10. that means if you don't
have sunscreen protection on
of at least 25 to 30 and up you're going
to burn in about 20 minutes if you're
very fair skin
at least start to burn all right windy
tomorrow still mid 90s
80s we slide a little on thursday but
look at those beautiful mid 70s friday
without the wind it's going to be a
beautiful spring weekend and we'll get
back to mid 80's on sunday